hi everyone my name is Zoey Blonsky I'm
from the Technion first of all thanks
very much for coming thanks for thanks
platica for hosting this thing's Kanaan
for inviting me I want to apologize most
of your data scientists probably I'm not
a behavioral economist those you don't
know we have of economics is a subfield
of economics in which we experimentally
in empirically tests how people behave
in economic situations and then we plug
that in to the models and probably the
most famous be able economists out their
most popular especially to the public is
this guy this is Dan Ariely I guess many
of you probably know him he was also my
mentor for my postdoc a very nice guy
very funny one he's very famous for this
book maybe most of you know the book as
lost in Alabama today but the title in
English is actually predictably
irrational so in Bayville economics most
people focus on the second word
irrational which makes sense this is
what people find very attractive so the
book demonstrates a lot of funny
situations in which people behave in a
way that looks a bit irrational but I'm
special kind of behavioral economist I
focus on the first part in the
predicting part of the behavior and I
guess this is why I chose this subtitle
for my talk which is when how can social
scientists add value data scientists so
data scientists I guess many times are
dealing with prediction are thinking how
can I help you do that by using theories
from the economics and it's not trivial
that I can this is Freddy Allen AK I you
probably know them a very very important
speech recognition researcher may be the
father of speech recognition he is often
quoted for saying every time I fire a
linguist the performance of my speech
recognizer goes up so this saying kind
of highlights a common wisdom in data
science that according to which
linguists and other social scientists
like myself and their theories are of
little use when it comes to actually
making predictions so they do their
theoretical research that's nice
that's not useful for predictions on the
other hand there's this guy he was in
see the head of my PhD advisor from the
Technion for the past 12 years or so
he's been organizing what is called
choice prediction competitions I guess
many of you know Kaggle tournaments so
this is very much like that we are
trying to we are hosting competitions
tournaments people are trying to predict
the data that we supply them with the
data is about economic choice behavior
and it's more a little bit more oriented
towards academic research so that's
basically the only difference in these
tournaments in our choice provision
competitions we see that machine
learning and data science submissions
usually rank very low so there's an
obvious discrepancy here between these
two people the findings of these two
people I say and one question is why so
there are many possible answers
well I think one important contributor
to this discrepancy is the fact that
data scientists and social scientists
they don't integrate well so we don't
have good methods to integrate practices
from both these fields and what I'm
gonna do now is go I'm gonna present a
very simple method to do that to
integrate the two fields so all right
okay to do that let's think of a very
basic depiction of data so we have a
black box let's call it nature we have a
set of features going in let's call it
set X and we have a response going out
let's call it Y and somehow within the
black box nature associates somehow
operates on X and Y to associate them
together and in prediction we don't care
about how it associates it
we are only care about finding the
function f such that f of X approximates
Y now the good news is that you guys
data scientists are really good at this
I give you pairs of x and y basically
you do some supervised learning and you
give me a good F what's missing here so
I should give you the x and y y is
usually a property of the task but what
are the x's what are the feet
that you are going to use in your
prediction now I think that if you think
about it when it comes to behavior
behavioral scientists are usually the
experts on this they've been riding for
decades thousands and thousands of
papers trying to prove to some extent
that a certain predictor X is associated
with a certain behavior Y so here's a
very simple method to integrate to
Mayville scientists will develop theory
grounded features data scientists would
give us the tools to integrate them
together and do that prediction in dress
of the table sorry in the rest of the
talk I'm gonna demonstrate that this
very simple method works very well in a
challenging setting although it's very
basic as well and I'm gonna briefly say
something about why I think it works in
this setting better than other data
science practices maybe stuff that needs
to learn the features themselves like
deep learning so this is the the setting
that were handling a very basic one
let's look at this for a second please
choose between a or b a provides three
hundred shekels with certainty B is a
gamble giving you four hundred shekels
in four out of five times zero otherwise
show of hands who here prefers a to be
okay who here prefers B to a alright
many of you don't have any preference
for free money okay that's cool let's
look at a second problem now a brings
you 300 with a chance of 1 out of 4 or 0
B gives you four hundred of the chance
of 1 out of 5 or 0 now show of hands who
prefers a who prefers B ok much more
many more so if you switched your choice
and you chose a in the first problem and
being a second problem all the other way
around you have shown a kind of
irrational behavior I'm not sure it's
irrational but let's say according to
the rational economic benchmark you have
shown irrational behavior let's see for
instance for a second why basically I
think you can think of this problem
problem 2 as a two-stage gamble
first nature or a random device that you
have nothing to do with chooses whether
you get to play or not
one for one out of four times you get to
play three or four times you don't get a
play if you get to play and this is
completely out of your hands then you
play problem one and then if you select
a you get 300 for certainty if you play
B you get that's four hundred and four
out of five sorry for that so basically
if you think about it if you change your
choice from problem one to problem too
then you basically did not choose the
same in the second stage of this gamble
which doesn't make sense to many
economists this is known as the LA
paradox a very famous one a paradox in
economics since the 1950s after Maurice
Allais who discovered it he won the
Nobel Prize for that and many other
economists who studied these kind of a
basic Gamble's won Nobel Prizes for
stuff like that and well that's maybe
important academically it may be it may
be it's important even for política but
you might say well that's a funny
example why do I care what applications
can we do that outside of maybe the
gaming domain so it turns out that this
is a very important problem in public
policy so recently Dan Ariely his
colleagues me amongst them are trying to
help the Department of budgets in the
Ministry of Finance that's a graft
activity matzoh to reduce traffic in
Israeli highways how do we do that one
suggestion is that we actually pay
people for to leave their cars at home
so if you don't commute to work using
your car you get some money now the next
question is how do you get the money how
do we pay you for every do we pay you a
fixed sum for every day you come you
don't take your car to work or do we
give you a lottery ticket
for every such day such that you have a
small chance to win big or maybe we give
you deposit some money in your account
at the beginning of the month and every
day you use your car we deduct money
from it there are many other different
ways to use the same
budget to give you the roared what would
make most people behave in accordance
with what we want you to do which is to
leave your other car at home so if you
think about this is exactly the type of
problem that we're studying in choice
between Gamble's we want to see how the
average person would behave in
accordance with a specific incentive
mechanism monetary incentive mechanism
so this is just a little bit motivation
why this is important even for
applications but it has a very important
theoretical importance as well so um we
collected a lot of data well a lot given
what we've we heard from platicas that's
that's ridiculous but considering I'm
coming from academia it's a lot of data
we have about thousand participants and
they played 270 different such problems
that like the one I've just shown you
not everyone played old games and it was
a repeated choice so they each picked in
the same problem of future several times
and they got feedback for that and we
saw how they learn over time basically
we've collected a dataset of 700,000
individual unique choices which is a
huge data set for academia for this
domain this was collected for a choice
prediction competition for choice
between competition in 2015 and this
means that we have very very good
benchmarks to compare our methods
against because we had 25 teams of
researchers from all around the world
submitting models trying to compete in
our tournament to see who can predict
human choice behavior in these economic
settings best and the winner was was
doing pretty well and we're now going to
compare our method to this winner now
the goal in this tournament was to
predict note the average choice over
time in new problems so I'm not asking
to predict an individual's choice in a
specific problem but I want to predict
the average across the population in
new problem this is kind of like the
traffic example from before I don't want
to predict how a specific driver whether
a specific driver would leave this car
at home what I'm interested in I'm
employing now a an incentive mechanism
I'm interested in which incentive
mechanism would make most of you the
average person leave their car at home
now so the just so we have a concept of
why why was the main aggregate choice
rates for option B without loss of
generality so here's the experiment we
did and the question for this experiment
our Theory grounded features useful or
and necessary for making a prediction in
this task what we did is we first simply
defined feature sets we plug these into
basic learning algorithms and then we
derive the predictions to see if they do
well here the three feature sets that we
tested first the feature set that we
call objective we just tell the
algorithm this is the problem that the
participants saw so you know that the
algorithm knows the exact Gamble's that
the participants saw naive is what most
of you may put into a learning algorithm
that tries to predict behavior in choice
between Gamble's stuff like expected
value and so on so stuff that anyone
would assume might matter importantly
there was a third feature set called
psychological which is handcrafted
engineered features derived directly
from decision-making theories example
there's a theory that says that people
are generally pessimist so people don't
like to lose the not to much so they
prefer the option that minimizes the
worst outcome someone feature two
captures it very simply is the
difference of three minimal outcomes
minimum outcome of B minus B modicum of
a if this features has a large value
then people a pessimist would prefer B
if it has a negative value a pessimist
would prefer a very simple a bit more
complex decision-making theory is that
people don't like regret and the
probability of regrets specifically is
very important and so to capture this we
just designed a simple feature that says
what is the probability of regret from
choosing a which is B providing a better
outcome in and then a minus the
probability of regret from choosing B
which is a providing a better outcome
than a and this is just capturing this
this idea here's the results of this
experiment so what you can see here is
the just some representations some
representative algorithms that we use
there were others of course and two
benchmarks this is random guessing
performance this is the winner of the
competition and two things to note here
first in this in these three columns
there is no cycle there are no
psychological features so we did not use
the psychological features in these
columns and what you can see here is
that no algorithm K even came close to
the best that we had by that which is a
purely psychological models developed by
psychologists noting machine learning
about it however once we did use the
psychological features along with
everything else then there was an
algorithm specifically was random
forests that outperformed the best that
ice the psychologists did in this task
and this is in a choice projection
competition so there were many different
submissions this is once the best so
this is the log scale so this is
actually a very good improvement about
25% or so okay two issues here that you
may think of first
this was a post hoc exercise so we
actually knew the data that we're gonna
test on of course we did everything
right and we didn't cheat but we already
knew the data we're going to test on a
new one someone might claim that well
you engineer the feature is not out of
decision-making theories you engineer
the features to fit the data are you
gonna test on a second problem is well
this whole exercise was under the
assumption that you know what you're
doing is a data scientist which I told
you are not and maybe more sophisticated
algorithms this deep learning and so on
would not require psychological features
to perform well so in order to solve
this issue we had a nutri specific
competition just recently in 2018 and at
two months ago so basically now we had
no idea what's the test data gonna be
because we haven't run the experiments
yet and we already committed to the same
method and we invited people from the AI
computer science as well to send better
models in ours the results were as
follows first the winner of the
competition basically used this method
they took our features one by one and
the only thing they did is instead of
using random forests they plug them in
extreme gradient boosting algorithm
that's all and that's what's the winner
of the competition so yet another
decision tree ensemble that won the
competition I didn't use xgb they did
they want second we had deep networks
sent to us and they did poorly so it's
not I can't guarantee that you can't do
better with deep learning because
someone might come with one and show me
wrong but so far we think this is very
very hard so and this method works very
well so one question is why in this
specific setting theory seems to be so
important for prediction because we know
that many times in many applications
theory
not that important in prediction so as
Hernan said first thing is human choice
is a very hard prediction problem and
there are many many challenges in human
choice predicament choice prediction can
I mention it I think he was calling it
framing I call it context it can play a
large role so for example you don't have
to have framing if you had a fight with
your spouse tonight before we might
change your behavior the next day if you
just had a really nice picture chocolate
you might change your behavior in our
experiments so there are so many
unobservable that is gonna be very very
hard to actually find everything ii as
cannon said also there is a lot a lot of
heterogeneity of tastes so people are
not the same people do not choose the
same in the same problem people even
don't choose the same over time in the
same problem the same person now this
might explain partly why we need a bit
of theory to go to move forward
second is that our data set is not in
the billions it's not huge it's the
largest ever assembled for this kind of
task seven hundred thousand choices but
it's rather small in in this for machine
learning for deeply but most importantly
I think is that the effective size of
the side of the effective data set is
actually very small recall that what
we're trying to predict here is the
average choice rate in a new problem so
we don't have data for this new problem
and we're only trying to predict the
average behavior in the population
basically our training data is just our
the behave the average behavior in the
problems that we already saw which is
just around 200 so that's the whole
training data we have that's a small
piece of data although it's very large
when considering public policy issues so
let me summarize I think
first of all human choice prediction is
invariant for many public policy
applications for example traffic and you
can think of some more for example
insurance company wants to encourage you
to drive more safely how would they
reward you for that and so on often
though when we're trying to predict the
average behavior and not an individual's
behavior which is many times the case
for public policy there's just a small
data set to learn from and in these
cases I think that integration of expert
knowledge can go a long way
using engineer features okay so that is
it just let you know that I'm having
talked to anyone interested in being in
grad students integrating social and
data Sciences in the Technion we could
drop me a line and if you have questions
I'm have the answer
[Applause]